bonsoir Valérie bonsoir vous étiez
présente à l'avrière vendredi soir le
communiste alainage tenait sa première
cérémonie de vœux depuis son élection
après le départ de Pierre séincour dans
le courant de l'année 2012 oui
absolument et une première totalement
réussie puisque malgré la neige qui
tombait déjà de rue he vendredi soir les
verrièrois avaient fait vraiment le
déplacement massivement dans la salle du
du scarabé de la verrière et les
politiques étaient très présents
également ette prière cérémonie de V
pour le ma oui c'était le cas notamment
de de Benoît amamont hein ministre
délégué à l'économie sociale et
solidaire et député de cette 11e
circonscription également Catherine
taska Sénat sénatrice des ivelines
Robert Cadalbert président de la
communauté d'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin et Michel Joe préfet du
département la cérémonie qui a commencé
par un rappel sur la situation au Mali
oui tout à fait car il ne faut pas
oublier que la verrière est jumelée avec
la ville de diabigé he une ville du Mali
et que depuis 2 ans c'est c'est un
ancien habitant de La Verrière Mamadou
Diawara qui en est le maire et donc
Alain hajage tenait absolument à sa
présence par le biais d'une conversation
téléphonique qui malheureusement était
totalement inaudible et qui donc a dû
être écourté pour autant al la Haage a
souligné qu'il était totalement d'accord
hein avec l'engagement des des troupes
militaires françaises au Mali al jaage
qui a également tenu à souligner
l'importance de la solidarité entre les
verrièrois oui parce que la la ville de
la verrière est à une une pauvreté assez
significative je rappelle qu'il y a 22 %
des habitants qui vivent en dessous du
seuil de
pauvreté 6000 habitants pour un revenu
moyen de
2230 € par mois et par ménage la ville
compte 70 % de locataires sociaux et
donc elle a un jage encourant encourage
les associations et les administrés à se
mobiliser pour les plus défavorisés la
priorité qui a été donnée au logement
pour cette nouvelle année afin de
répondre à une demande toujours plus
importante en logements sociaux oui et
c'est le le cas du du du lancement de de
la concertation publique entre habitants
et élus dans le cadre du projet urbain
gare bécane qui a eu lieu ce samedi
outre le logement le but de ce projet
est de désenclaver la ville en
multipliant notamment les transports
mais aussi de multiplier les offres
d'emploi et de services grâce à des
zones d'activité alors bien sûr alin
jaage précise qu'il n'y aura pas
d'effort au niveau des impôts réclamés
au ver roi des partenaires publics et
privés devraient financer le projet en
question en février d'autres ateliers
avec les habitants se tiendront à La
Verrière car le maire souhaite avant
tout construire ce projet en totale
concertation avec les habitants un
dernier mot peut-être pour terminer sur
ces jeunes qui étaient présents aussi
font partie du conseil municipal oui de
nouveaux élus donc pour cette toute
première édition des conseils Municipal
des Jeunes franchement élu depuis le 10
janvier dernier ont été présentés à
l'occasion de ces vœux 2013 leur premier
pas en tant que représentant politique
merci Valérie demain dans la prochaine
édition du 78 le point sur les vœux de
voisin le Bretonneux nous verrons ce
qu'il faut retenir de la cérémonie de
l'UMP alexibiet on en revient donc à la
neige et je vous le disais en début
d'édition elle tombe toujours à 50 ans
Eveline alerte orange maintenu jusqu'à
22h ce 21 janvier la préfecture des
ivelines qui a décidé de rétablir les
transports scolaires à compter du mardi
22 janvier au matin un petit point sur
vos conditions de circulation elles
étaient difficiles dans l'agglomération
en fin de journée aux alentours de 16h30
ce non pas en raison du sol glissant
puisque nous l'avons entendu le Conseil
général nous l'a précisé les routes ont
été salées c'est surtout à cause de la
circulation importante nos équipes ont
relevé plusieurs kilomètres de bouchon
notamment à Saint-Quentin en iveline
également pour relier Saint-Quentin en
iveline depuis saint-cirque l'école
soyez prudent avec le froid qui va se
faire plus important au cours de la nuit
et du verglas qui pourrait bien
évidemment arriver dans un instant
comment prévenir les risques du cannabis
auparavant la neige c'est aussi fait
pour s'amuser vous allez le voir
un weekend sous la neige c'est ce que
les cinquantinois ont pu connaître en
cette fin de semaine depuis samedi le
paysage a revêtu son plus beau manteau
la neige le weekend une équation moins
problématique que les intempéries en
pleine semaine ainsi parents et enfants
s'en sont donné à cœurjoie j'aime bien
la neige alors dis-moi ce que tu
voudrais faire une descente ah ouais
pourquoi faire une descente je sais pas
pour aller vite oui très sympa avec les
enfants avec les deux filles on profite
de ces contraintes temporel on va dire
pour faire du un peu de luge puis après
on fera peut-être du ski de
fond je avec un copain pour pour aller
faire de l'alluge bah parfois on se
gamelle et parfois
non malgré les apparences ce n'est pas
forcément la descente la plus périlleuse
la montée elle aussi réserve quelques
surprises la neige faire un weekend
prolongé sur le territoire cinquantinois
elle devrait laisser place au verglas et
à la pluie dans les jours à venir mais
les prochains flocons reviendront très
vite ils sont attendus dès jeudi
DESC